s Sal mat welcome welcome so nice to
have you aboard s you are contemporary
Bobby Fisher you have so many marvelous
stories now president of the Marshall
chess Foundation introduce yourself to
our audience and and we can't help but
ask about Bobby fiser stories please uh
take it away as yasa said my name is Sal
Mata I'm the uh I'm a vice president of
the Marshall chess club and a president
of the Marshal chess Foundation um a
little bit later we'll talk about the uh
the Fisher archives sure um yes I knew
Bobby many many times he was taught he
was always at Jack Collins's house right
so many times I would just go to the
house and usually about 10 or 11 o'clock
at night Bobby would show up because
that was he was sleeping all day those
were his hours those were his hours he
actually uh went he would when I won the
US jior he went over all the games um
and I remember there was one I was very
very proud of and he just sort of looked
at me said you don't really really have
very much here do
you
okay but he was always spoton and very
very quickly understood what was
happening the downside of analyzing with
a genius right S I mean my goodness it
was amazing yes yeah and you had this
really nice story just a moment ago
you're telling me about pal benko who
was a candidate Master at the time
trying to teach Bobby that the Boni was
unplayable tell our audience how that
worked out so actually this was the last
round of the uh the US Junior Chess
Championship which I won um and luckily
I was I managed to get one and a half
points ahead of brown in the Bolta Brown
in the last round um and we got to a
very very complicated position I was the
white side of the bononi um obviously
Brown is is black uh he's dying to beat
me um and I come to a point where I'm
looking at this very complex move and I
can't really calculate it to the end but
my gut is saying that's the right move
right um and among other things it
probably it might have gotten Walter
into time pressure which he loves which
he always was getting into and just at
the moment I was about to make the move
Bobby fiser walks in because he used to
attend the US Juniors you know
continuously and I just froze and I
played some general move and Walter just
crushed me immediately okay on the
afterwards we it was held in the chess
club which was in the Henry Hudson Hotel
we all Walter and I went thinking we
were going to have our postmortem right
to look at your game and we sat down and
immediately bko and Fischer pushed us
aside bko took the white side which was
my side um uh Bobby took the the black
side because of course he loved to play
the bononi and they just started
analyzing this game Brown and I were now
Irrelevant for the whole the whole
circumstance and it was just amazing
because it was one of the first times
this is a candidate the two TW two time
C he was a seriously strong player right
right and no matter what he did to try
to control Bobby right he's trying to be
you know the great strategist and you
control the board etc etc he couldn't
control him Fischer would just always
find incredible counterplay uh and it
was just like really amaz and brown and
I just sort of looked at each other
because we' seen none of this stuff um
and but I think we act afterwards we
talked about I said you know there were
Grand Masters and then there's this guy
Bobby fiser and there's something
different there something special there
and I think we even said this is
probably a world what a world champion
is like how old was Bobby at this time
what year uh I was 16 in' 67 so he was
born in
43 6 I can't do the
math 20 something right gotcha um but oh
well I mean just this idea that you were
around this Legend and saw him growing
up today you are uh president of the
Marshall foundation and you came across
a lot of materials that Regina his mom
had kept
tell us and where did they end up where
are they today so well the tars um uh
Russell and Regina uh Bobby's sister had
um they donated Joan sorry yes uh
donated 20 to 25 boxes full of uh
original score sheets um carbon copies
of course cuz that's what we all had we
didn't have those um the AR Arbiters
took away our Originals why yeah the G
of his of his first book Bobby Fisher's
games of Chess uh many many photographs
correspondents etc etc and they donated
it to the Marshall chess Foundation
because they wanted to have a tax
deductible donation which they did uh it
sat there actually arrived in 2008 which
was the year that Bobby died at the age
of 64 which as you know is symbolically
important to chess players um and
nothing happened with it and um I'm
suddenly the president of the Marshall
chess foundation and I thought it was
very very important to to get this sold
um and initially it was well let's see
if we can get some money for it and I I
went to um auction houses and try to
contact private people and then at some
point I I was thinking about it going
wait a minute this is Bobby fiser okay
this is the most important stuff in the
world um for chess players and I didn't
want to see a diaspora cu the the um the
auction house started talking about it
we sell it a lots I said what's that oh
we private and put in ch you'll get
you'll get the F the score sheets for 59
blah blah blah I said that's wrong so I
got in touch with um Shannon Bailey of
the World Chess Hall of Fame and I said
I think this is the place this belongs
you need this and um after a lot of
negotiation and discussion you know we
we we worked out a deal right and
literally two days ago John Donaldson
was here and he and I were pouring over
the collection and and helping to
catalog it which you need chess players
to be able to do it so I'm very very
happy about that because I feel it's
found a home it's found a home it's
found the right home um so I'm I'm
delighted just a second you're telling
me that boxes and boxes of Bobby Fisher
training games have been uncovered on
Earth so these are score sheets that's
nobody beside yourself and John have
seen in ages they're about 14 or 15 that
no one has ever seen wow okay so what
I'm hoping it's also interesting because
you look at the games and let's say
they're late 57 and in about a month
he's going to win the US Championship
right and he's up a pawn and a rook and
pawn ending and can't convert it and you
sit there go what happened in that very
short period of time he just went from
he figured it out right somehow he
understood chess and then he won the US
championship and a year later he was a
candidate and you know he was just
amazing yeah a lot of this just very
interesting so how did he go from there
to here um in such a short period of
time how'd he do it I don't know come
on if I had the secret I wouldn't be
here dude you're on the show for a
reason we brought you we thought you
were a specialist I don't yeah it's
remarkable is yeah it really is it's
like a genius just suddenly BL he's got
it um so it was very very exciting so
anyway um I'm very happy done that
Christian you got an opportunity to ask
uh Bobby Fisher stories and what it was
like growing up in New York uh with
intern I'm sure we will hear a lot about
that but I do want to ask you about some
of the players in this champion ship
specifically our leader right now abanu
Mishra is there do you see any
similarities between himself and Bobby
uh actually yesterday's game I was very
impressed uh that he was Ray Robson
against that that it was everybody the
three of you were trying to figure out
what was going on exactly with theine
with the engine and and I thought that
know he just seems to have a incredible
ability to play in very complicated
positions I I get the preparation yeah
but what I'm impressed with even more is
just the overboard over theboard
capability of of playing such a
complicated game and and queen d8 rookie
s he understood where he had to place
his pieces to meet the requirements of
the position just incredible it was very
very impressive um s I'm going to put
you on the spot right here right now I'm
going to bring up the game uh of Mishra
today because it's a very complicated
position as we were coming into our
studios here here he is he's white he's
up against um Hans Neeman and the last
few moves were this whole ideas that we
had seen Queen A3 putting pressure on uh
whoops I think was not play you wanted
to play yeah I think actually this is
our analysis let me uh Let me refresh
the board for just a moment and this is
what happened not what we were looking
at Bishop G5 Rook E8 takes takes 94 take
it away what is going on and would you
ever yes exactly dude we're putting you
in the hot seat I'm I'm looking to take
a
break well it's oh he took he already so
we're going to see Rook takes
E4 uh well I think if I were black I
would not be happy about the broken Pawn
structure and I think that's a good I I
like the idea of Rook B8 because
otherwise Rook B1 would have been very
strong and wasn't that Queen just on A3
a move or two ago no no we were trying
to put it there that was our analysis
the queen uh slid over to C1 earlier in
the game and we were looking at ideas of
Queen A3 in order to Target this Pawn on
E6 you may you mentioned the double
pawns but this uh control of the
bile just your evaluation uh would you
rather play Black rather play White I'd
rather play white but I think black has
a lot of counterplay here um and I think
Queen A3 is not a move because of Queen
B2 at this point exactly Queen A3 3
Queen B2 trading the Queens seems to
help only uh Black's cause and playing
something like Rook E2
looks okay little okay it's okay just
like but then maybe I don't know C5 I
feel at some point maybe it's going to
turn into an okay you get my Pawn on A2
something like Queen 2 E3 you go Queen
B2 I move the Rook back without the Rook
on E2 I don't like this mean like Rook
B8 Queen let say queen E3 right Queen B2
you go Queen B2 I move my Rook you take
my Pawn on A2 and then I start an attack
on the king side with G4 I I I feel
that's going to be the race that we're
going to see right absolutely I I'm not
sure you actually answer the question as
MRE did you do you recognize greatness
in Mishra as well well this is the first
time I've really followed his games
closely and and live is a whole
different feeling you really start to
understand what what people are doing I
I was very impressed with yesterday's
game absolutely K and I have a question
so you were a US Junior Champion you
played in the US championships how does
it feel to be here today to analyze in
this studio to see how you know the Hall
of Fame how the playing Hall where their
players are playing well I think it's
fantastic I mean it's just it's one of
the reasons I came to St Louis one was
to to help John with the archive with
the archive but a lot of it was just
first of all to see the St Louis chess
scene uh and to also attend um a modern
US modern US Championship do you miss
playing this tournament sure sure I'll
I'll tell you one last memory um which
is again of Bobby I mean you this is
very very sophisticated the setup you
have here and I'm sure you know that
when Bobby was playing we had no such
thing of course so what they had is the
play The Players would be playing and
then uh there would be large
demonstration boards behind them the
audiences out there so they could follow
the games um and I worked the wallboard
so I was able to to work one of B
I'm a yes absolutely so I actually U was
was the the guy who was following
Fisher's moves and relaying them and
well putting them up on the board um and
he was this was the I can't remember
which US Championship it was but he was
had been playing only the Kings Indian
uh which we were talking about yesterday
with Carissa etc etc and all of a sudden
he started playing the nimso Indian uh
which nobody had seen before with the
the old that special line where quick B6
Bishop A6 right um and he was black
against Sadi of course STI I think was
completely taken back that he was not
prepared to the teeth for the king's
Indian and uh and there was a point
where Bobby it was I'm probably an
expert at this point I'm going well he
could probably do that that sacrifices
an exchange of some compensation of
course he plays it and just crushes
Sadie I was very impressed it was sort
of nice to make you know be the person
who was like making those moves on the
board pretending it was
me that was my idea I thought of that
yeah good work Bobby so thank you so
much for coming it was great to have you
with us today absolutely thank you so
much nice to meet you and I also just
want to say one last thing the three of
you do a wonderful job oh you're only
saying that CU it's true yes it's true
it's wonderful it's great thank you so
much thank you very much and here can't
go away okay uh here we got the pairings
uh to show you uh everybody